Eric lang is a designer known for his  work on the excom and Star Wars card  games and now he's tackling blood-borne  I'm Tony and this is your lovecraftian  gamespot news update the blood-borne  card game is based on chalice dungeons  and the goal is the same as in the video  game kill monsters and don't die each 30  minute game will require risk assessment  inventory management and tactics there  aren't any mini figures included with  the game but lank says it will include  some quote sweet components the  blood-borne card game doesn't have a  release date yet but it's officially  licensed so you can expect a certain  level of quality when it does release  you can also expect plenty of death keep  an eye on gamespot and we'll keep you  updated